foreign
start off by uh thanking you all for
your hard work and uh and just I want to
express my immense admiration and
appreciation for everything you've done
to build a giga Nevada and to help
revolutionize the world
this this this Factory is made a massive
effect on transitioning the world to
sustainable energy
and it's something you should be
incredibly incredibly proud of and I'm
incredibly proud of you guys for doing
it so yeah
[Applause]
let's see
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
building this Factory and achieving a
tremendous output of cells about drive
units Power Electronics
stationary battery packs
but there's more so
it's hard to believe that it was almost
a decade ago that we started that we
started building this place
I mean I can remember coming out here to
the Tahoe Reno industrial complex as
it's interestingly named
and it was nothing there was just rocks
and uh and now I've got this incredible
Factory it's the most advanced uh
cell and battery and powertrain Factory
in the world and
yeah it's literally from a polarized so
it actually took it took me a moment to
think enough I
uh I spent so much time in this Factory
since I actually was camping out on the
roof at one point on a little tent
um just to sort of save time from going
to the hotel is pitching pitch a little
tent on the roof and lived there it gets
pretty cold at night
um but just coming in here and seeing
all the snow on the ground I mean this
is such a a beautiful area that we're in
um and uh the wild horses I think people
sometimes don't believe me it's just
it's it's a basically like paradise
around here it's a a I think it's 10 000
Wild Horses uh just roaming around
um snow on the mountains
you get tightly Tower nearby
um so part of this by the way is a
recruiting call for
um because we're going to need a lot of
people so
um
definitely talk to your friends and
family and about to come and work here
because we're going to scale up big time
and it's going to be great so
yeah
um yeah
[Applause]
so it's interesting to see the original
goal
um where we thought you know
uh
you know at the time people thought this
was a crazy amount of batteries to make
in fact this was when we started out
this this one Factory was set up to
build more Lithium-ion batteries in the
rest of the world combined
and it Remains by far the biggest
Factory in North America
and um and the reason we built it was
because there literally weren't enough
Lithium-ion batteries if you took all of
the factories in Earth combined it
wouldn't be enough to make electric
vehicles at scale so that's why we
concluded we had to build a factory a
really big Factory which is why we as
the gigapart comes in
um so it it's uh one of the biggest
factories in the world and it's it's
going to get get bigger
um so in in 2014 we we projected uh 35
gigawatt hours of battery cells and um
yeah and we're there so we've done 6.2
billion dollars of investment it's a
over five million square feet uh 11 000
team members and we have 3 200 Acres of
which we've still only used a small
portion so we've got plenty of room to
to grow and I should say that the you
know what I'm announcing today is
actually not the end of it it's just
really phase two
so there's going to be like phase three
and and forming it really it just takes
a tremendous amount to transition the
world to sustainability you've got to
have giant factories uh if we are to
move the world to a sustainable energy
future
and um
yeah so it's it's great
so where we are right now is we've we've
made seven over seven billion cells or
actually almost more cells than people
so
[Applause]
and we've done over three and a half
million drive units so my Motors and
Power Electronics
we've made a million energy modules for
stationary storage
so it's yeah exactly it's what I always
remind people we also make stationary
storage that's very important
I mean the three elements of a
sustainable energy future the three
pillars are electric vehicles stationary
storage and then solar and wind and
because solar and wind are intermittent
you have to have the stationary storage
to store the power for when the wind is
blowing the sun isn't shining pretty
basic really so it's a three-step three
pillars and this is all very doable and
will be done and and will bring
civilization to a sustainable energy
future so that's yeah
[Applause]
and in terms of the economic uh impact
is really substantial six billion
dollars of total economic output every
year
so we've also put uh
37 million dollars into K-12 education
and we're going to increase that
so and focused on Robotics and
sustainability so
[Applause]
so just uh yeah once again uh thank you
for your incredible work to bring us to
this point
um and um it wouldn't obviously
thanks to you so this this photo is is
uh from millionth energy module that we
made just last Wednesday so
um yeah the risk of being repetitive
thank you very much
foreign
was just the beginning
well phase one at least
and so we're
um what we're announcing today is a
massive additional investment
and here's a sneak peek of what the
factory will look like
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it's gonna look so it's like it's a
heck
so
uh I mean you know one of the other
things that's really cool is we actually
achieved our production goals with
basically about half of what of the
space we thought would be needed so uh
now we're going to fill out the other
half and uh so we're you know on to
phase two so we're going to be investing
and I should say these are conservative
numbers so we expect to exceed these
numbers I think we'll end up investing
over 4 billion we're adding another four
million Suite of square feet of
manufacturing space and at least three
thousand jobs they're direct jobs and I
think it'll probably end up being more
than that these are conservative
estimates so yeah
[Applause]
foreign
so yeah so we're we're going to do our
high volume semi-truck manufacturing
here
um and uh
and then we're also going to be adding
100 gigawatt hours of uh 40 of Tesla
4680 cell manufacturing here and that's
just to start I think long term we may
do as much as five uh yes as much as 500
gigawatt hours long term but this
increment is 100 gigawatt hours
and um
yeah so
hugely important uh game changer
so just some videos of 4680 production
we expect the new cell Factory as I said
to produce uh
at least a hundred gigawatt hours and as
I said that's that's really just to
begin with
long-term Tesla is aiming to produce
well over a thousand gigawatt hours
possibly
two two or three thousand so this really
is just the start
and that's equivalent to one and a half
million additional model 3y vehicles
and they will also be using 4680 for
stationary storage as well
um and typically this is in addition to
our suppliers
so when you think about the fact that
there's uh two billion cars and trucks
on the road globally
um obviously you've got to build a lot
of electric vehicles to replace all the
gasoline powered vehicles and then
about as much as what again is needed
for stationary storage of forest
sustainable energy so
um
yeah it's uh it's actually really
incredible to think about so
and um
yeah some people have said this is
impossible but you can drive it
so
[Applause]
and in fact we already have Tesla the
Tesla semi truck in use by some of our
key customers like Pepsi and
um so that this year is kind of like the
limited production of the semi truck and
then hopefully uh sometime next year
we'll be able to achieve volume
production
um and uh
it's a it's a game changer
so uh although uh trucks semi trucks are
only about one percent of the vehicles
they're actually responsible for 20
percent of the emissions
so it's a it's a much bigger effect than
you'd think if you just looked at the
number of vehicles it's an essential
part of a sustainable energy future
uh and this is a this is a beast you can
see it'll hold an ass up in the mountain
there pretty cool
so
so and um I'd like to say just a a also
a big thank you to the state of Nevada
and um
I'd like to invite Nevada Governor uh
Joe Lombardo to Johnny
[Applause]
well first and foremost you guys look
awesome
[Applause]
and I want to thank Elon I want to thank
Elon for his partnership and helping
improve your quality of life my quality
of life and changing the world so thank
you round of applause for Elon
so I appreciate everybody coming
together today to give me the
opportunity to say hi first and foremost
and hopefully some of you saw my State
of the State last night did you
[Applause]
hopefully I said some things that made
you happy made you happy but I think we
will so what is my role in this process
that we're talking about today and
obviously elon's here to change the
world
I'm here to change your life well that's
very clear
um I I'm just I get too I get way too
much credit if the credit is theirs no I
understand that
so Elon talked about his three pillars
with electric energy right you got the
EVS you got the storage and you got wind
and solar
so my three pillars as your Governor is
the economy education and your quality
of life slash Public Safety
no that's all part of it
so the economic driver is obviously
Tesla that is changing the environment
and your lives in Nevada's lives
with your placement here in the state of
Nevada and now today with this expansion
it's even at a double the quality of
life and the economic engine and the
drivers for us to be successful in the
whole state of Nevada in particular to
Northern Nevada and so there's a young
man in the in the audience that just
came on my team Tom Burns can you come
up here
if you don't mind sir okay
[Applause]
so you in the back can't see him he's
short
but uh Tom is the new director of the
governor's office of Economic
Development and he is the one
instrumental in partnering with Tesla
and ensure that we get this project off
the ground and built and ensuring that
it goes in perpetuity into the future so
thank you Tom
[Applause]
so that's the economic pillar right
that's the economic pillar so the
education pillar
for the labor force for the engineers
and and everything else it takes to run
a village especially something as
magnanimous as Tesla takes a education
system in a university system to produce
those individuals to occupy those jobs
and there's a very important person in
the audience I'm going to bring up and
it's former Governor Sandoval come up
here
so you may not know
but he's also the president of UNR where
a lot of you might have went to school
[Applause]
so the president of UNLV was here a
little while ago but decided to leave
and which upsets me because I'm from
UNLV and I wanted a little competition
going on here
but I appreciate uh Brian Sandoval being
here and and for those who also may not
know
Ryan Sandoval and Elon had a handshake
agreement several years ago that started
this whole thing in its infancy so thank
you Brian thank you for your support
thank you
and the last piece in this is your
quality of life slash safety in
particular to I-80 right here right
[Applause]
Gracie Tracy can I get Tracy up here
Tracy Larkin come on up
[Applause]
who's shorter Tom or Tracy so
so for those of you in the back there's
a young lady up here she's the new
director of the Department of
Transportation
I informed her her major task her
primary task is expansion of I-80
creating a safe environment for you to
go to and from work
and to ensure that semi truck gets on
the road and gets out of here
all right all right so that's what we're
going to do for you for the state of
Nevada and that's what I'm going to do
for you as the head of state of Nevada
and hopefully we can partnership with
you into the future and ensure we have a
very very very long-term relationship
and everybody gets to be friends so
thank you all right thank you thank you